my name is Morris Davis and about some a
decade
go i was a member of the UK government's
ministerial advisory panel analyst
trade and I can see some other of my
former panel members here at that time
we achieved a few things we got the US
UK government to finally ratify the
UNESCO 1970 convention and a few other
things and we also in a subsidiary piece
of work produced some guidance called
combating a lytic illicit trade aimed at
UK museums and as far as i can tell
those guidelines are still in use by UK
museums and what those guidelines did
was to set a standard for UK museums
that said if there was any doubt about
the licit pneus of an item then museums
should avoid it and essentially the
requirement now for museums in the UK is
that to acquire an item you either have
to have clear evidence that it was out
of the country of origin before nineteen
seventy or that it has proper export
documentation from its country of origin
and what sure I've been away from the
issue for about a decade and what's
really struck me here today is how the
volume of illicit material that's being
trafficked has really hugely increased
since those days now in those days we
had a much lower standard for the art
trade where the art trade codes don't
set this if any if you've got any doubt
avoided standard and we've heard cases
today of things appearing on the market
lots of them and I suppose I would like
to ask our panelists if they would like
to see the art trade adopt a standard
similar to that in museums where really
if you have any doubt about an item
almost if there's any possibility it's
been looted recently you should simply
avoid it I'd be interested to hear what
what the panelists think about it we
certainly have a member of the art trade
who's going to be speaking later on this
afternoon and perhaps it would be better
to wait until he's available to actually
address address things if James is happy
with that excellent okay sue miller from
echo moss i have one comment and one
question i'm very interested that much
many of the talks have said how much
capacity bill
is needed how many jobs for
archeologists and heritage professionals
are required and I have a skepticism
that this is in a sense war is job
creation destruction is job creation for
our industry on a large scale I don't
know if anyone wants to comment on that
but that's a general impression I'm
getting and that's not a cynical comment
it's one of capacity building and one of
that in a way our cultural heritage
industry is not accepted as a large
scale industry sufficient to achieve the
objectives after post-conflict that
everybody's been talking about and link
to that I have moved from a
straightforward archaeologist a museum
professional to being very much involved
in cultural tourism internationally and
I'm prompted to ask this question after
lassan ECC's contribution who's a member
of the international scientific
committee for e-commerce on cultural
tourism sixty percent of the business
opportunities afforded by cultural
heritage have gone in northern Mali this
is very key they've gone to a large
extent in Libya if the continued
destruction goes on they've gone to a
large extent not in museums but in the
wider archaeological sites in Iraq and
they're going in Yemen so my concern for
us as heritage professional is where are
the priorities for future development
when I saw the YouTube video my concern
was we will create a Nimrod Disneyland
with all our documentation of
photographs our experience and our
expertise we will have eventually
Disneyland in Iraq it may not be a bad
thing but I wonder what the panel thinks
as the microphone switched on well I
won't attempt to answer all of your
questions there was a whole series of
them and comments i think but only one
which was what you said towards the
beginning about job creation i'm very
clear in my mind at least with iraq
which is all I'm qualified to speak
about that anything that anybody does
must be to support the Iraq government
and I think that's the help that they
need when we talk about capacity
building we don't mean sending foreign
archaeologists to Iraq to help them sort
out the mess that rather providing
resources so that in the long run they
could they can do it themselves so I see
it very much as an effort to provide
it's not it's not just expertise but
money they're going to need masses
amount of money and expertise as well to
sort out this terrible mess and that's
where we'll need to help them in due
course I'll leave the other parts of
your question to other panelists
okay Amy I would like to comment on the
capacity building question because the
capacity building is not our idea it's
really the wish of the countries we were
working in they want us to help them to
educate our colleagues and the students
in these countries and for example
Tunisia hired about 200 new conserved
conservators after the Revolution which
are urgent need of training programs so
this is a few very much connected to 220
research as you know German
archaeological Institute as a research
institute which has a history of 185
years and capacity building was not all
the time part of our engagement in other
countries but nowadays we it's almost
impossible to think of working in
countries and other countries without
that aspect it's extremely important and
it's a maybe more important than other
parts of our engagement in these
countries to Iraq in this respect the
ministry of tourism and antiquities
there one year ago hired 500 new
employees for the for the ministry or
for the State Board of Antiquities and
heritage all of them come from
universities with a be a level and
without any practical expertise so to
our experience and our concern is that
vice versa without a proper
yeah further education we will create
Hollywood sceneries over there so
developing an understanding on cultural
heritage approaches according to
international understandings is more
than necessary for my feeling creative
jobs for archaeologists but although the
opposite as I mentioned in my my talking
the academics on muscle University
essentially are now ben de unemployed
they in forced you to flee the city so
they they're no longer in work right now
and when you hold only hope that at some
point will be able to return and take up
again their their work in and around
muscle with the help I think we need to
the extent we can to provide them with
yes Catherine hickley I'm a journalist
and I have questioned because there have
been a lot a lot of talk in the
newspapers about a potential military
force to protect antiquities and
international military force and I
wonder for those of you working on the
ground and who know these regions very
well whether you can see any situation
where that would be beneficial helpful
or necessary even or whether you think
this is something that will disappear a
bit of a hot air discussion
well I can address this in terms of
volume essentially at the very beginning
of the start of the conflict the
military was tasked to some degree to
protect him up to and its heritage now
the will the army wasn't wasn't strong
as to stand up to the the forces that
ultimately invaded Timbuktu and this has
been the case in all the major cities in
the north in some instances I think in
some countries like Molly the military
itself is not representative at least
ethnically of the people who live in the
northern part of the country and so
essentially it's very difficult to send
different cultural groups up to northern
Mali which is a whole different region
and cultural region and have them
protect cultural monuments there's not
interest in terms of the groups that
make up the military and there's
resistance from groups to these southern
ethnic groups coming up and protecting
these these monuments so it's a bit of a
complicated situation and unfortunately
I don't think the military resolution is
going to help this is the same for Yemen
especially in the tribal area was a
control of the state government it's not
working at all there's no way to protect
aside by military so it's the only way
as as I try to express this to employ
that the state employees of tribal
people and that they pay the tribe of
people to keep the sides and to keep the
fines from the sides